hello everyone and welcome to another
video where we will observe how most
interesting positions can arise out of
the Berlin defense regardless of how
many times it's being played uh it is
and uh I seem to have uh I've forgotten
the update to do this rating because it
is a bit higher
uh let me just fix this there we go uh
and yeah we have a former world champion
former World classical champion and
former world uh two times rapid Champion
vishwanathan taking on youngstov dudam
it's quite a brutal game you guys will
enjoy it let's check it out a lot of you
have requested it it's from yesterday's
round one we've seen a round two where
we should play it against the Magnus so
here Pawn to E4 by which Pawn to E5 like
we've said the Berlin defense will be on
the board Bishop the B5 Lopez and Knight
to F6 the Berlin defense D3 uh we have
Bishop to C5 and now Bishop captures on
C6 with the characters and C6 and now
Knight B to D2 for those of you who are
perhaps just joining us in the Chess
World you might be wondering why not
grab the Free Pawn uh well of course
Queen D4 and white resigns as white will
either lose a rook uh Knight or get
checkmated on F2 so here Knight B to D2
now this is prevented and Knight the D7
now you have to defend the E5 pawn and
this is done in this line of the Berlin
defense by other playing Bishop D6 or
queen t7 or you pin the knight from
Bishop to G4 or you play Knight to D7
which will allow black to at some point
push F6 and black always plays F6 in the
brilliant defense I've yet to see a game
where black doesn't maybe if black
blunder is the game before it's time to
play F6 but they always play it so
Knight to C4 puts more pressure on E5
and now just castles and here it
actually is possible to capture the pawn
but it's not a it's not a great move uh
for example if Knight captures an E5
Knight captures Knight captures now
Queen goes here attacks the Knight and
goes after the F2 Pawn you can play
Knight to G4 it is possible as you
defend the pawn and now after Bishop
captures Queen captures you even allow
Queen captures on F2 liugo King to D1
and you're not down material or anything
you will even play Queen to F3 if black
allows it and it's not not the end of
the world but for example if F5 which is
the only move that gives black the
advantage then you will run into some
trouble for example characters captures
captures captures and the black is just
um up too much
inactivity black is just too active Rook
is coming to F2 the other Rook you can
easily go to E8 to f8 uh the bishop is
already developed and you don't have all
that many great squares to develop this
bush we have to play like Bishop D2 to
C3 and so on so it's not going to be
easy to
uh to get out of this uh in case you
were wondering so here we have castles
uh and now Rook the E8 we have King to
H1 and of course spawn to F6 at night
stage for now preparing to come to F5
and now Knight The Fate now the bishop
nicely covers the F5 square and usually
everyone played yeah Bishop to E3 here
in this position but Anand played Knight
to E3 and it is now as of move 11 that
we have a completely new game now Anand
is ready to claim that F5 Square for
himself uh and that there doesn't seem
to be anything you can do about it of
course you can play G6 but that's a
further weakening on the position uh you
know you want to think twice before
doing this it is you know in fact the
best move by the engine but of course to
do that does not know that so Knights
the G6 and now Knight H to F5 now you
claim the F5 square and you know Queen
to G4 is coming next and H for H5 and
you will probably Checkmate the black
king if black allows all of this so uh
you should probably avoid getting your
Bishops for Knights the bishop captures
on Eve 3 or even Bishop captures on F5
uh should be considered at least
ill-advised you should continue with
something like A5 and then after let's
say queen G4 King then after H5 H4 Rook
to G8 so the G7 Pawn is nicely defended
and it's uh not a problem the Knight can
come to E7 you can trade off the knights
uh and so on so uh the knight from F5
cannot really move it's a fine position
but uh of course uh you do not know this
and it's a rapid game Bishop captures on
E3 was played Knight captures on E3 and
now Bishop to E6 so do that nicely
develops B3 now uh and queen to D4
putting pressure on The Rook here so
Rook B1 preparing Bishop to B2 to kick
away the queen Rook 8 to d8 and now
Bishop to B2 with Queen back to D6 and
now Pawn to F3 uh just uh solidifying
here in the center we have Pawn to C5
now the D4 square is definitely uh taken
by black and of course the knight from
G6 as G3 will probably be played will
come to E7 then to C6 then to D4 and you
will either leave it here or take it or
maybe play C3 in the future but then
your Bishop becomes useless so uh it's
uh it's not a bad position for Black by
any means sorry not capture than E5 it
did not happen I accidentally played
that so G3 taking away these squares
from the Black Knight and of course now
B5 we have Queen to E2 uh stopping C4
and now Rook to D7 we have Rook to F2
and now Queen to C6 preparing C4 and
also nicely aligning the queen with the
white King on this diagonal uh when you
do that on you know more often than not
good things will happen so here Pawn to
H4 preparing Pawn to H5 and now Pawn to
C4 do that counter attacks on the queen
side with d captures D B captures and B
captures on C4 now Anand is up a pawn as
the pawn is nicely defended uh but how
are you uh Gonna Keep that pawn I mean
it's a double C Pawn if anything they
are they are both weaknesses so here we
have Queen to C5 now should the Knight
and queen move even The Rook will be
suspiciously placed here on F2 so you
should play something like Bishop C3 to
B4 to grab even more space on the queen
side Anand first moves the root back uh
it is rapid you are done on time you
don't wanna
uh over Press Your Luck uh Rook eat the
d8 nicely doubling up on the D file now
preparing Rook to D2 and of course Anand
stops at Bishop to C3 defending and
attacking well potentially attacking so
Queen to A3 but now uh just Rook to B3
showing that the pawn cannot be captured
if you capture is Rook to A1 uh traps uh
uh do the screen so I have to Rook to B3
uh we have Queen T6 again putting
pressure on that C4 pawn and of course
you cannot Advance it as the queen would
hang on E2 uh Pawn to H5 uh you sold all
of your problems on the queen side and
you once again have the privilege of
attacking the king side H5 with Knight
to D7 and now Pawn to H6 and now you do
want to play G6 but you also know that
that's not great if G6 then F4 will come
then this diagonal uh becomes open then
this bishop becomes a monster and you
have a whole other set of problems so
it's basically what what kind of
problems do you want in life so Knights
the C6 do that can changed with his plan
of putting the Knight to D4 you really
want to kill that Bishop on C3 and now
Rook the E1 Rook the B1 also a nice move
Anan goes for Rook to E1 Knight to D4
now you have to trade as your queen and
um
uh rock around the attack and Bishop to
D for uh capturing uh we have Rook
counters on D4 you could also play e
Captain D for but then Knight to D5 and
F4 will be uh well at least a nuisance
for black so uh Rook captures on D4 and
now H captures on G7 so for the moment
of course you will ignore this you got
rid of the dark Square Bishop so it's
time to claim that uh d uh not just the
D file but also the second rank uh Queen
to F1 and now King captures on G7 Anand
plays uh Pawn to G4 so now you know that
at some point Knight to F5 is probably
coming if you capture then the G file
opens up rook comes to G1 uh could be
very nice for him and now Queen to A5
Queen to A5 is a super tricky move uh
for uh Duda but only if Anand messes it
up the the point is that if you play
something like Queen to H3 okay it's a
very nice move you want to start
attacking uh Rook H2 check and then the
Rook hangs on E1 and you have at least a
draw basically you have nothing to worry
about with black hair white lost the
attack okay Knight to F5 is no longer no
longer does anything I mean it's it's
nice but doesn't do anything Rook to B7
uh is easily easily defended so you know
nowhere is there however Anand plays
Queen to G1
and now the idea is of course the queen
lift is coming but it's coming via the
G3 Square then you will be able to enter
push G5 and so on but also the rook and
E1 will be defended so here H6 should be
played as that G5 push really needs to
be stopped a Duda played King to G6 this
is how he stops IT Queen to G3 now of
course G5 will be putting pressure on E5
as well uh and uh Queen captures on A2
again H6 was the only way to go but now
Pawn to G5 and there's no good way to
handle this uh to give you an example if
you play real captors on C2 let's say
you want to trade Rooks Knight captures
Queen captures white just plays uh
captures on F6 opens up a discovery from
the queen after the king captures Queen
H4 check connects with the Rook connects
with the H7 Pawn after King F7 you can
even play Rook to B7 I mean now this is
a threat this is a threat this is a
threat uh there's no move here that that
black can make to survive this so
instead F captures and G5 was played but
now Queen captures an five and it seems
like Duda is getting completely wrecked
but he finds a move that keeps him in
the game Queen to A6 just defends the
bishop and everything is perfectly fine
next move H6 is coming and he solidifies
but there is one move that wins the game
for Anand so feel free to pause this
video and try to find the only idea that
wins uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always finding
that one true path towards the
opponent's king and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Pawn
to F4 this is the only move that wins
for those of you who found the Rook the
B5 Rook to G1 which is very nice they
are both easily paired by Ponte H6 so
the G5 phone becomes defended and that's
pretty much it you will still have a
nice position but it's not crushing
after Pawn to F4 is just crashing now F5
is a threat Queen captures and G5 is a
threat there there are no uh moves here
you have to capture the pawn so G
captures an F4 and now Knight to D5 by
Anand uh it's a rapid game so of course
you will uh sometimes play a sub-optimal
move but uh Knight to D5 is still
winning for White Knight F5 I will
however just show it uh it's an Instant
Checkmate
uh you cannot avoid this queen uh Queen
can come to G7 with check then Queen
comes to H6 work to G1 depends on what
black plays but he is just crashing and
of course if you capture the knight uh
then still Rook the G1 with check and
you have an almost King F7 will be met
with Rook to G7 checking the f8 and now
Queen to sorry uh Queen to E7 uh will be
Checkmate and if you don't if you after
Knight to F5 you play something like
this you defend the at the G7 Square
still Rook to G1 check King F7 Queen to
G7 with check King to E8 and now Rook
the B8 with check even and that's it
Rook to d8 you free up D7 Square for the
White Queen is Checkmate so just showing
it for fun but anand's move is also
uh more than sufficient the Knight is
coming capturing an F4 Rook the G1 check
97 all of these are just um you know
possibilities Queen is now also covering
the the F6 Square uh you cannot defend
this uh so Bishop captures on D5 was
played but now Rook to G1 checked and it
was in this uh position unmove 40 uh
that Yang shished of Duda resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here point is that after King the H6 of
course The Rook to H3 is just Checkmate
and if you go up the board it's the
exact same one that we've already shown
Brooke to G7 checking to f8 and queen to
E7 will be Checkmate uh so beautiful
beautiful attacking game by vishwanathan
Anand like I said another game where we
showed just how full of possibilities
the Berlin defenses and no matter how
many times we see it there's always a
way uh to not have a boring game to have
a brutal attacking game and this is uh
you know one such example of course it
helps that it's not classical it helps
that it's rapid uh but you know uh
definitely I I have enjoyed it you guys
have as well and it just shows that it
doesn't matter how strong Duda is and
how uh you know how how far up in in the
world he is uh Anand is just a former
World rapid Champion doesn't matter how
old he gets doesn't matter uh what
happens he will always be able to beat
anyone uh you know anywhere in in any
position in any opening uh so yeah there
you have it I hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank ABC's of chess
openings for kids
bulletchestriller.com Samuel Kane Dan
McCormick and James Eugene Cashman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon uh continuing the coverage
of this wonderful tournament checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and sorry about my voice being
a bit sore I'm a little bit under the
weather hope it will pass soon uh see
you soon enjoy your day